on aborde comme entretien avec le
sourire et le soleil compétitions les
plus suivis du département la course
royal est une nouvelle fois réuni plus
de 10000 runner les athlètes spécialiste
de l'épreuve où nos vies sont venus des
quatre coins de la france pour courir
dans les jardins du château de
versailles
c'est versailles c'est la course dans le
château de versailles c'est super 15 km
à des parcours différents et du fait
beau et c'est top c'est ma troisième
course à versailles j'ai fait les
princesses et ma deuxième royal et puis
je cours régulièrement je fais pareil de
course
doc versailles c'est parce que c'est
beau mais c'est parce que c'est
l'occasion de faire une course et y en a
pas beaucoup les 15 km pour cette
sixième édition les organisateurs
avaient concocté un parcours plus
technique des dernières années objectif
répondre aux exigences des coureurs
chevronnés
on passe du pavé au sentier à l'herbe
donc c'est un petit peu technique certes
des difficultés qui n'ont pas empêché
hamid belhaj de s'imposer le runner a
bouclé sa course royal en 49 minutes et
6 secondes
il devance de 35 secondes nicolas
dalmasso c'est le nouveau record de
l'épreuve
les records sont être me sens prêt pour
être battus mais là il ya des jours avec
des gens sont aujourd'hui c'était avec
et on voit là le record de l'épreuve est
tombé mais voilà c'est comme ça
le sportif tentera de défendre son
record l'année prochaine une septième
édition est déjà programmée pour juin
[Musique]